what'd I just say your name man it just
it comes with so much class in so much
respect when you walked out it was like
my dad man like like I have that much
admiration for you in what you've
accomplished and then miss this movie
your caddy me award-winning actor their
Nutcracker the four realms and just
seeing the roles you take on you embody
them what is your secret
learn the script primarily you know what
you're really good at what's the horse
amen
you were born to that yes sir that's
just natural it comes you don't have to
work too hard to do it maybe I work hard
to keep the body going towards me keep
up with that but the actual doing that
becomes nevertheless me enacting I am an
actor so you said there was so much
confidence there's so much so I mean
just that that that that Cologne just
came off you when you said I am an actor
well yeah it's some point in your life
for some reason I'm not much more than
that I want to be a good person but I am
only an itinerant actor I can identify
because honestly the character that I
created in college was entitled
primetime that was far detached from me
mm-hmm
I'm really reserved I'm a country boy
I'm laid-back I like the fish man I like
anonymity I like being with my kids I
like being playing daddy I don't like
the crowds and handclaps but the role I
took on to make sure that my mother net
never had to work another day in her
life was prior and I see you take on so
many different roles that the
believability is so authentic is there
any challenge that you say you know what
or do you challenge yourself that way
well yes I do
and yet there there is at least two
challenges one that I will never forget
that I couldn't rise to and I asked a
couple of other activity if trouble with
this room they were man yes I'll tell oh
wow
really hard to play what then what I
have my thoughts about it
I don't think William knew any black
people okay so there are things in there
that are just Shakespeare but don't
speak to that particular character it's
hard to do well so so when you choose
your scripts of your excitements what's
that process like just reading a book if
you start reading a book and you enjoy
the book you'll know first first second
page if it's got your attention the same
thing with the script if I read this
script and this story itself gets my
attention then I'm really curious about
who they want me to play most of the
time I already known but in Shawshank
Redemption for instance I know that's
classic classic yeah I said to my agent
any role I'll do anything in this story
no it was this a simple any role I are
you doing I'll do I'll do anything all
and and then he said well they want you
to play a read that's like that's the
entire movie so it's a simple process
it's simple to you but it's not simple
to me because when I watch you being at
a high level in my profession seeing you
over a long period of time perform in a
high level III think did you do you ever
tire did you you ever tire of not to
hustle but the fight to want to show who
you are and get the accreditation for it
and which of it what you're asking and I
I can honestly say I'm past that stage
now I'm on the downside I think of
thinking about Korea okay I'm more
thinking about playing golf you like
golf yeah
I can't get into golf because every
golfer that I've ever met is upset for
some type of reason that they're not at
the place that they want to be and I
don't need nothing else in my life to
upset me because I have a peaceful life
here with you this is the challenge of
it
I think of golf as really the game of
life life is something that you
continually tried to improve on Wilson
it's the same with golf and that's why
we're all kind of upset because you
don't have anybody to blame for your
mistakes
but you Ray well I mean I cost myself
out
tell me about the plight of Tiger just
coming back I'm like everybody else in
the world I guess I want the best for
that guy here you go
because nobody excited the world of golf
the way he did and he went at it so hard
that he damaged himself I mean I heard a
commentator say watch you know I've seen
this guy win a tournament with a broken
leg but can't do anything with a broken
mind well I think he's fixed his mind
but he's gonna have to join the seniors
tiers seniors tours to really make a
comeback it's so funny that every
athlete I know I have this affinity and
this affection to entertain in every
entertainer or actor or someone that
performs as well has this affection and
affinity for athleticism it's like an
exchange and I've never been able to
Mary or intertwine the two but it's like
an exchange
we admire what you do so much but then
there's another reciprocal admiration
that what we do so that's why your
affection for golf that's why I'm
affectionate for Ike teen or television
that's not weird we like all athletes I
don't care what the calling is a young
person or persons of manner who has that
much control over body I mean you watch
Major League Baseball and guys climbing
defenses and coming down with home runs
inning love things like that
shortstop I mean making it play with
yourself how do they do that
yeah yeah I think you admire what you
will never be able to do and the kids
are different these days man and as I
grew old on 51 and baby baby but the
kids are so different and I'm used to
this certain generation it seems as
though nobody want to work anymore for
what they're receiving no one wants it
like they once did no one has the
sacrifice like like we had to it that
maybe a large portion of society but I
don't think us no one's situation
because we still have people excelling
it's still coming up out of you don't
know we're excelling that means they
worked at it you are a poster for it's
never too late
thank you you started I mean you started
acting in the 60s like you'd actually
started acting when I was beat okay
I started making money at it was my
fifties yeah yeah a long haul you know
but like I say it's the same as golf
mm-hmm and where are you lose based on
your choices tell us about the movie The
Nutcracker it's well people know about
Nutcracker the ballet which I've really
seen an owner two or three times in New
York ah
this movie is not a ballet there's
ballet in it but it's an adventure story
this young girl who's I think
Drosselmeyer is like her Godfather he
raised her mother so she goes to him for
her and he has a sort of magical mindset
mm-hmm
he makes these incredible toys and
things and he has secrets and he knows
stuff
he travels is whenever he's like Marco
Polo in that sense it will he's been
ever waiting knows a lot a lot of people
know him very generous very rich but
that child is his charge as it concluded
what did you say to yourself about the
movie as you concluded when it was a rat
do you know when you go in and do these
movies I'm gonna go into the middle of
situation I'm gonna do two or three
scenes and then I'm gonna go home okay
so a wrap for me is not a wrap for the
movie I only hope always that the people
who said I was that was terrific
really mean it can you give me this is
last thing I need a day in the life
can't give me a day of Morgan Freeman
man cuz I'm fascinated with you they're
in their life we're off the set you're
not acting I'm at home I'm you you're
the crib okay get up
I made coffee I took about an hour to
drink the coffee and I am a solitaire
addict
also a puzzle addict and I'll either do
one of the other users I do the daily
New York Times crossword puzzles I have
it on my iPad okay and then I'll take an
hour and a half of work out in the gym
and then I'll eat usually a sandwich and
then I'll go and play golf
that's a day but you you have so much
going on there Madam Secretary as well
it's its hundredth episode you're
embarking upon yeah there are a lot of
people to thank for that
yeah and primarily my producing partner
Laura McCreary she's awesome in season
three of National Geographic as well
yeah you know you're busy thank heavens
yeah you know I'm I'm happy to be long
as I got something to do I think people
look at me said well you look you look
well you always look well and I love the
title story of god mmm
you know I mean that's the way I live so
it's a very interesting concept and a
very interesting job yes
I get to go everywhere and talk to
people who think beep you think deep as
a result I appreciate you man okay thank
you
I mean you you have no idea how much you
mean to me and how much you motivate me
and what you mean to us you keep talking
okay I am you really doing nothing but
good stuff you do you I love it you have
no idea the impact that you have and I
think it's a good idea but I don't have
a good idea I mean my head's big enough
now you know it's much bigger yeah
and me walking around wobbling yeah well
being a Cowboys fan you're not gonna
wobble long that's gonna stop you from
wobbling okay because there's a lot of
adversity in that how do you know it's
cowboy wonderful people that I handle or
a lot of stuff
aha yes yeah okay we gonna pray about
them Cowboys okay mmm you know dak
Prescott comes out in Mississippi State
yes he does so and he said good human
being yeah and he's a good quarterback I
protect him a lot yeah they don't
everything at it but I protected my like
give him some weapons so they not I got
him one they got a got a receiver Cooper
I'm the Raiders hopefully that paid
dividends
yeah of course it will I appreciate you
man thank you so I appreciate you we got
the Nutcracker the four realms man
coming out Friday this Friday November
the 2nd in theatres oh what an
experience amen
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience